so i'm interested in finding the
relationship between people's height in
inches and their weight in pounds and so
i'm randomly sampling a bunch of people
measuring their height measuring their
weight and then for each person i'm
plotting a point that represents their
height and weight
combination so for example let's say i
measure someone who is 60 inches tall
that would be 5 feet tall and they weigh
100 pounds and so i'd go to 60 inches
and then 100 pounds
right over there so that point right
over there is the point 60
comma
60 comma 100. one way to think about it
height we could say is being measured on
our x-axis or plotted along our x-axis
and then weight along our y-axis and
this point from this person is the point
60 comma 100 representing 60 inches 100
pounds and so so far i've done it for 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 eight nine people and i
could keep going but even with this i
could say well look it looks like
there's a roughly linear relationship
here it looks like it's positive that
generally speaking as height increases
so does weight maybe i could try to
put a line that can approximate this
trend so let me try to do that so this
is my line tool i could think about a
bunch of lines something like this
seems like it would be you'd be most of
the data is is below the line so that
seems like it's not right
i could do
something like
i could do something like this but that
doesn't seem like a good fit most of the
data seems to be above the line
and so and once again i'm just
eyeballing it here in the future you
will learn
better methods of finding
a better fit
but this something like this and i'm
just eyeballing it looks about right
so that line you could view this as a
regression line we could view this as y
equals mx plus b where we would have to
figure out the slope and the y-intercept
and we could figure it out based on what
i just drew or we could even think of
this as weight
weight is equal to our slope times
height
times height plus whatever our
y-intercept is or you could think of it
if you think of the vertical axis of the
weight axis you could think of it as
your weight intercept but either way
this is the model that i'm just
through eyeballing this is my regression
line something that i'm trying to fit to
these points but clearly it can't go
through one line won't be able to go
through all of these points there is
going to be for each point some
some difference well not for all of them
but for many of them some difference
between the actual and what would have
been predicted by the line and that idea
the difference between the actual four
point and what would have been predicted
given say the height that is called a
residual
i write that down
the a residual
for each of these data points and so for
example if i call this right here if i
call that point one the residual for
point one is going to be well for
for our variable for our height variable
60 inches the actual here is 100 pounds
and from that we would subtract what
would be predicted and so what would be
predicted is right
over here
i could i could just
substitute 60 into this equation so it'd
be m times 60 plus b
so i could write it as
m maybe let me write it this way 60 m
plus b once again i would just take the
60 pounds and put it into my model here
and say well what weight would that have
predicted and i could even just for the
sake of having a number here i can look
i can
let me get my line tool out and try to
get a straight line
from that point
so from this point
let me get a straight line
so that doesn't look quite straight okay
a little bit okay
so
if i it looks like it's about
150 pounds so my model would have
predicted 150 pounds
so the residual here is going to be
equal to
negative 50.
and so a negative residual is when your
actual is below your predicted
so this right over here this is r
one it is a negative residual if you had
if you tried to find let's say that
let's say this residual right over here
for this point
this r two this would be a positive
residual because the actual is larger
than what would have actually been
predicted
and so
a residual is good for seeing well how
good does your line does your regression
does your model fit a given data point
or how does a given data point compare
to that but what you probably want to do
is think about some combination of all
the residuals and try to minimize it
now you might say well why don't i just
add up all the residuals and try to
minimize that but that gets tricky
because some are positive and some are
negative and so a big negative residual
negative residual could counterbalance a
big positive residual and it would look
if they would add up to zero and then it
would look like there's no residual so
you could just add up the absolute
values so you could say well let me just
take the sum
of
all of the residual of the absolute
value of all of the residuals and then
let me change m
and b for my line to minimize this
and that would be a technique of trying
to create a regression line but another
way to do it and this is actually the
most typical way that you will see in
statistics is that people take the sum
of the squares of the residuals
the sum of the squares and when you
square something whether it's negative
or positive it's going to be a positive
so it takes care of that issue of
negatives and positives canceling out
with each other
and when you square a number things with
large residuals are going to become even
larger relatively speaking you know if
you square a large
you know one is if you think about this
way let me put regular numbers one two
three
4 these are all one apart from each
other but if i were to square them 1 4 9
16 they get further and further apart
and so something the larger the residual
is when you square it when the sum of
squares is going to represent a bigger
proportion
of the sum
and so what we'll see in future videos
is that there is a technique called
least
least squares
squares regression
least squares regression
where you can find an m
and a b
for a given set of data so it minimizes
the sum of the squares of the residual
and that's valuable and the reason why
this is used most is it really tries to
take into account things that are
significant outliers things that sit
from pretty far away from the model
something like this is going to really
with at least squares regression is
going to try to be minimized
or it's going to be weighted a little
bit heavier because when you square it
it becomes even a bigger factor in this
but this is just a conceptual
introduction in future videos we'll do
things like calculate residuals
and we'll actually derive the formula
for how do you figure out an m and a b
for a line that actually minimizes the
sum of the squares of the residuals